In this video, we'll put everything
together we seen before in,
in expressing the different gradients
in a neural network and, uh, obtain, uh,
one efficient procedure for computing
the gradients with respect to our
parameter. And that procedure
is called backpropagation.
So now we've seen in a previous video
and expression for getting the grain and
with respect to all the parameters in
the neural network, that expression,
depending on the gradient
of the hidden layers, uh,
which d also depending on the gradient,
uh, with respect to the output.
And so now we'll see how can put together
all of these different expressions to
obtain a procedure that will efficiently
compute the parameter gradients.
Yeah.
All right. So, um, we've
seen in the first video how,
uh,
the gradient of the loss function with
respect to the pre activation at the
output layer correspondent to
this expression. And then, uh,
we also saw that the gradient with respect
to the activation in the hidden layer,
a curse upon the two,
that expression and a then we saw that
the gradient of the loss function with
respect to the pre activation of a hidden
layer responded to that expression.
If finally we saw that the gradient of
the last function with respect to either
the a matrix of connections or devices
corresponded to these two expressions
here and now we know this,
that in each case except
for this one, uh, s uh,
in the expression on the left,
it would often depend
on the gradients of uh,
other parts of the neural networks.
So the gradient of the weights and the
biases depends on the gradient with
respect to the pre activations,
uh,
the gradients of the hidden
unit activations dependent
also on the green and
the, the pre activations. While
the grain of pre activations, uh,
actually dependent on the gradient of
the activation of a hidden layer and at
the output layer.
Also we had the formula for getting the
gradient of the pre activations at the
output layer.
So here the procedure we see,
which is the backpropagation algorithm,
the idea is to apply
these formulas in order.
So that on the right side here,
we always have a precomputed everything
to actually compute that expression.
So let's go into the steps of
the backpropagation algorithm.
So first we assume that we've already
done a forward propagation. That is,
we've computed, given the input,
the value of all the hidden units,
uh, all the hidden layers and the output
layer. So we've computer already f of x,
and that's because before we
computed each of the, uh, activation,
uh,
of each hidden layer h of x.
And now we'll, we'll do is that we
initialize the pre activation gradient,
uh, at the output layer
that's layer l plus one,
and we'll uh,
we'll initialize it or we'll set it
to the value of what that gradient is.
That is minus the 100 factor,
uh,
for labeled y minus the output layer.
And then we'll iterate from layer,
uh,
l plus one to layer one,
and we'll perform these updates,
these computations here.
So first we'll actually compute
the gradient for the current layer.
So I'll call Kay the current hidden layer
at which we are during our iteration
here. So we compute the gradients
of the hidden layer parameters,
the lid,
the parameters for a hidden
layer cake or hidden or you know,
cake because it can be,
I'll plus one that could be,
this could be the parameters
for the output layer as
well depending on the value
of k.
So we can compute this because
we've already precomputed the uh,
reactivation gradient.
So we have the value for this.
So now we just take the outer product
of that vector with that vector and that
gives us the gradient for the uh,
weights and then the gradient for the
biases as we seen as just a gradient with
respect to their p activations.
And then will compute our,
propagate the gradient
to the hidden layer.
Below that is will compute the grain of
the loss with respect to the activation
for the layer right below
the layer came on a swan.
And we've seen that this just corresponds
to taking the pre activation gradient
and multiplying that by the transpose
of the connections between the current
hidden layer k and the inner layer below
came on his phone and then will compute
the gradients. But before the activation.
So the pre activation gradient,
which we see here,
and we've seen that occur,
spawns to taking the
gradient of the activations.
And I'm doing an element
wise multiplication with
the activation function,
the narratives at the value
of the activation function.
And so once we, uh, reach
that part of this, uh,
iteration in the loop,
uh,
then we now have the pre activation
gradients for came on this one.
So now we're ready to go from a
given value of k two a one a two.
The value of k, uh, that's,
uh, well, one less. So we,
for instance, if we started at a
value of k, which is Alpha Swan,
we'd be ready to go at a Caples
l and then kcals l minus one,
and so on until we reached
the last hidden layer.
So a, this is the backpropagation
algorithm and we see that actually, uh,
uh, does the sort of the
opposite, the forward propagation,
instead of going from the input
layer to the output layer,
it goes from the output layer and then,
uh,
it goes through the hidden there in the
reverse order from the top most in layer
to the bottom line.
There's a visual illustration of the
computations we have to do when we do fall
forward and,
uh,
backpropagation and this is also going
to give us some hints on how we could
implement for them backward propagation.
So we can write for propagation as an
acid clip flow graph where we have boxes.
So we see the boxes here with the,
the different variables that we
have to compute when computing, uh,
all the hidden layers and upload
layer and then the last function.
And so initially we have to set
our input layer to some value x.
Uh, well, so assume that we know
what are the current parameters of,
so these are the boxes that contain the
priorities of the current value for the
parameters.
And then what we do is that we compute
the reactivation for the first in the
layer,
we compute that from the input and the
biases and the weights of that hidden
layer.
Then from the pre activation
and we compute the activation
of the hidden layer.
And then from that and the parameters
for the second hidden layer,
we can compute the pre activation for
the second hidden layer. And for uh,
two hidden layer neural network.
We could then compute the output and
then from the output we could compute a
loss associated with this output.
Given that the true label is why,
okay,
so that actually gives us a nice
way of potentially implementing for
propagation.
So each buck could be an object and would
have a forward propagation or f prop
method that would take uh,
the parents of the box to the parents of
that object and a compute the value of
the box.
So for this box here,
this would be a box that would
compute a linear combination of this,
this and that.
So the reactivation,
this box would be an type of object
that computes a particular activation
function from the pre
activation and so on.
Okay.
So then performing for propagation would
just be crisp onto calling the F prob
method for each box,
for each object in the correct order
from the parents, which have no children.
And then computing it
for, uh, the other, uh,
boxes for which we have the value for
all of their parents and proceeding
forward until we reached
the last function.
And then if for this,
these, all of these objects,
we also had a beep prop method, then
we could compute, uh, backpropagation.
In fact,
we'd get the sort of for free,
we get a procedure for
computing all the gradients, uh,
of all of these boxes with
respect to the last function.
And this is called actually,
uh, automatic differentiation.
Um, so what it's a, in this setting,
what the be prop method would do is that
it would compute the gradient of the
loss with respect to its children. So, uh,
and uh,
so we have a beep prop method that
would depend on the boxes parents.
So, uh, the f prop
depends on its children.
It performs a computation
with respect to its children,
whereas be prop with
performance computation,
but with respect to the boxes parents
and indeed if we go and look back at the
formula for computing the great influence
suspect to the reactivation or the, uh,
uh, the, sorry, the activation
or the parameters, the, uh,
the formula always depends, uh, uh,
on the parents of these boxes in
this illustration here. So in fact,
doing backpropagation would
correspond to Coleen be prop,
but in the reverse order of
the graph. So, uh, in fact,
we'd start with this box and then
it would refers to the Arrow.
And then at this point we'd be ready
to call be prop for this box here,
which would compute the,
uh,
this will compute the greatness of
the last with respect to f of x.
And then from that we could reverse
this Arrow and now we'd have a,
we'd be ready to compute
the gradient of the loss.
But now with respect to this,
using the value and the great end that
I've been computed at this box here and
we can continue.
So like this,
we could back propagate the
gradients up to w so the grain,
so w would be computed based on the
value in the gradients computed here.
Same thing for B and we couldn't,
we could continue like
this and the inverse order.
Okay.
The reverse order to get the
greatest respect to everything,
you actually don't need the
grain with respect to x. Uh,
because we're only interested in
updating the values of the parameters.
So for that reason, we don't actually need
to continue in that part of the graph.
You don't need to compute the grading
with respect to x goes for performing
backpropagation and training the
neural network. We don't need it. Okay.
So this is just a, you know, a few
hints on how we could actually,
by using your flow graph,
the compensation of the
forward propagation and uh, uh,
using in this photograph objects to
have a forward propagation and the
backpropagation method.
And that's proper nippy prop.
We could actually get a fairly
flexible implementation, uh,
Ford propagation and backpropagation.
And we actually get from
the Ford Propagation Graph,
we essentially get a procedure for back
propagating the gradients almost for
free.
Now whenever we implement
a backpropagation and the
computation of you really
have any gradient, it's always a
good idea to verify whether, uh,
we haven't introduced any
bugs in our implementation.
And a one approach for that,
which is often news, is, uh,
uh, is to compare with a finance
difference approximation of the gradient.
So the idea is to notice that,
uh,
by definition the partial they live of
a function with respect to x is taking
this expression here.
So F of x plus some epsilon minus F of
x minus some epsilon divided by the size
of this gap between experts
apps and on the x minus epsilon.
So to my times epsilon and
taking that expression and uh,
taking epsilon, uh, um, um,
pushing it towards zero. And, uh, of
course we can't do that on the machine,
but what we could do is to actually
take epsilon and, and fix it to a very,
very small value to sort of get an
approximation of the real thing,
which would be to, uh, push,
uh, uh, epsilon towards zero.
So in our case,
where we could do is in this formula here,
f of x would be our loss x
would be one of our parameters.
So maybe,
you know,
it could be w I a Jay
for some hidden layer k.
And so computing f of x plus epsilon
would correspond to computing the loss
where we've taken the current
value of our parameter.
But we've added some epsilon value,
some very small value,
like say 10 to the minus six and F of
x minus epsilon would correspond to a,
again,
computing the loss,
but where we would have subtracted
epsilon from the current value of our
parameter.
And so by doing this,
we could compute that expression and that
would give us an approximation of what
the partial derivative of the loss with
respect to our parameter a would be.
And, uh, then we to, uh,
so we could compare that value of the
estimate of the partial data for our
parameter with the actual value that
backpropagation as a computer and a,
so this knee,
this means that if we want to test the
implementation of the computation of the
partial derivative with
respect to every parameter,
so all connections between all the
hidden layers and also all biases bik,
it means that we will need to do a
forward propagation with plus epsilon and
minus epsilon for each parameter.
So when we do this computation,
this finite difference
approximation for debugging,
we actually do it on a very small
neural network with very few parameters,
few connections and few biases.
And so once we get all the partial
dude is approximated with this fine I
difference. And when could we
can compare it with the uh, uh,
the, uh, computer gradients.
The computer partial data is
with respect to all parameters.
We could look at the absolute difference
between the average absolute difference.
We could look at the angle between the,
uh,
approximated gradience and the actual
grade we computer with a finite
difference. And if the, if the, if
this difference is a very, very small,
then we, uh, can be failed.
He assured that our implementation
and backpropagation is, is correct.
So that's a very good trick to know about
if we want to debug and implementation
of backpropagation.